hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live nach Sondierungsgesprächen hinter
verschlossenen Türen wo man nichts
gehört hat wollen sich SPD Grüne und FDP
heute dazu äußern ob sie nun
Koalitionsgespräche miteinander beginnen
wollen wir sehen Sie hier schon bei der
Pressekonferenz wir schalten live nach
Berlin und ordnen das ganze danach für
euch mit hauptstadtkorrespondenter
Nicole Diekmann ein
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich begrüße Sie herzlich zu
den pressestatements anlässlich der
Sondierungsgespräche von SPD Grünen und
FDP als Gesprächspartner stehen Ihnen
zur Verfügung der Kanzlerkandidat der
SPD Olaf Scholz
die die
Parteivorsitzende der Grünen Anna-Lena
baerbock der Parteivorsitzende der FDP
Christian Lindner die Parteivorsitzende
der SPD Saskia esken der
Parteivorsitzende der Grünen Robert
Herberg und der Parteivorsitzende der
SPD Norbert Walter borjans das Wort hat
Olaf Scholz bitteschön
einen schönen guten Tag ich freue mich
sie alle hier zu sehen wir haben in
dieser Woche intensiv gearbeitet auch
gestern noch einmal bis heute früh
morgens miteinander viel gesprochen und
geredet um all die Dinge vorzubereiten
die für die heutigen Beratungen dann
erforderlich waren und tatsächlich ist
es gelungen wir haben uns auf ein Papier
einen Text zur Sondierung verständigt
der jetzt die Grundlage für die
Entscheidung in den Parteien bilden kann
und aus der Perspektive die ich für mich
formulieren will ist das auch ein sehr
gutes Ergebnis es macht deutlich dass in
Deutschland eine Regierung gebildet
werden kann die dafür Sorge tragen
möchten dass wir einen Fortschritt
erreichen ein Fortschritt der möglich
und notwendig ist in vielen vielen
Feldern unser gesellschaftlichen
Entwicklung unserer wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung und auch im Hinblick auf die
Aufgaben die wir als Land in Europa
haben das haben wir konkretisiert in
vielen Fragestellungen die für uns
wichtig sind ganz besonders geht es um
die Modernisierung unseres gemein
Wissens wir wollen dafür Sorge tragen
dass viele Verwaltungsabläufe schneller
und digitaler werden dass wir aber auch
alle notwendigen Entscheidungen die für
den ökonomischen und investiven Aufbruch
in Deutschland notwendig sind so treffen
dass sie schnell zustande kommen können
und dann gibt es viele Felder für die
wir das für uns in Anspruch nehmen und
wo wir das voranbringen wollen das eine
große Thema ist die industrielle
Modernisierung unseres Landes die so
gelingen muss dass wir es gleichzeitig
schaffen den Menschen gemachten
Klimawandel aufzuhalten und es bedeutet
dass wir ein massiven Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien brauchen damit es
möglich ist dass wir so schnell wie
möglich auf die Nutzung fossiler
Ressourcen verzichten können genau das
haben wir uns miteinander vorgenommen es
wird das größte industrielle
modernisierungsprojektes Deutschland
wahrscheinlich seit über 100 Jahren
durchgeführt hat und das wird unser
Wirtschaft und unseren wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten sehr nutzen
wir haben gleichzeitig Sorge dafür
getragen dass die Gesellschaft
zusammenhält es gibt Fragen die viele
von uns bewegen und die wichtig sind
schaffen wir es dass die Kinder gute
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten haben ohne das
Kinderarmut weiter unser Land begleitet
kriegen wir es hin das genügend
Wohnungen in Deutschland gebaut werden
und dass wir das große drängende Problem
des wohnungsmangels lösen können wir
sicherstellen dass die Bürgern und
Bürger dieses Landes sich darauf
verlassen können dass sie eine sichere
und stabile Rente haben das genau haben
wir vereinbart dass das für die nächsten
Jahre gelingen soll gleichzeitig aber
auch sichergestellt dass die
Rentenversicherung mit zusätzlichen
Mitteln ausgestattet wird um in der Lage
zu sein dass sie dann auch die
demografischen Herausforderungen
sichererer bewältigen werden bewältigen
kann als ohne das und wir haben uns fest
vorgenommen dass wir für Respekt und
Zusammenhalt morgen da spielt die Frage
des Mindestlohns eine große Rolle und
der besseren und tariflichen Bezahlung
in vielen Bereichen unserer Gesellschaft
alles Fragen über die wir uns
verständigt haben neben vielen vielen
anderen die eine Rolle spielen und
insgesamt kann man sehr spüren hier ist
ein Aufbruch möglich getragen von den
dreien Parteien die hier zusammenkommen
für mich persönlich dass wir Dich gerne
noch sagen ist es sehr bemerkenswert wie
vertrauensvoll und konstruktiv die
Gespräche über auch unterschiedliche
Ausgangspositionen stattfinden das ist
etwas das ich als sehr sehr wohltuend
empfinde weil es schon jetzt während der
Sondierung dann hoffentlich bei
Koalitionsverhandlungen und noch viel
mehr wenn es darum geht miteinander zu
regieren dazu beitragen kann dass hier
das angepackt wird was für Deutschland
notwendig ist das haben wir uns
vorgenommen und wenn die Zusammenarbeit
weiter so gut klappt dann glaube ich
wird das auch eine gute Zukunft werden
für unser Land
auch von unserer Seite schönen guten Tag
schön dass Sie alle hier sind und
herzlichen Dank auch an ihr Verständnis
in den letzten Tagen dass wir sehr
vertrauensvoll miteinander gearbeitet
haben weil in diesem besonderen Moment
wo drei Parteien zusammenkommen auch aus
unterschiedlichen Richtungen
zusammenkommen die Grundlage dafür dass
wir hier heute ein Vorschlag für unsere
Parteien machen können mit Blick auf ein
gemeinsames sondierungspapier vor allen
Dingen war dass es ein vertrauensvolles
Gespräch gibt wo man auch offen über
Unterschiedlichkeiten sprechen kann um
dann gemeinsame Wege und Brücken zu
finden und das ist uns gelungen gestern
Nacht noch bis in den frühen Morgen in
intensiven Gesprächen gelungen einen
Vorschlag für eine Reform und
fortschrittskoalition auf den Weg zu
bringen um das nächste Jahrzehnt
wirklich als Jahrzehnt der Erneuerung zu
nutzen und damit wir nicht nur auf dem
kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner weiter
Politik in diesem Land machen sondern in
einer fortschrittskoalition auch für
eine wirkliche Erneuerung sorgen war es
wichtig dass bei drei unterschiedlichen
Parteien ein Verständnis da ist dass
jeder auch mal was gibt dass wir die
großen Fragen unserer Zeit auch wirklich
mutig angehen können und mutig angehen
können bedeutet dann auch den Mut zu
haben Entscheidungen zu treffen damit
wir bei den Zukunftsfragen wirklich in
diesem Jahrzehnt die Erneuerung auf den
Weg bringen können das ist vor allen
Dingen die große Frage der
klimagerechten Gesellschaft des
klimagerechten Wohlstands und eine
Erneuerung der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
hin zu einer sozialökologischen
Marktwirtschaft in Deutschland und damit
auch in Europa zu verankern und zugleich
dieses Jahrzehnt des Fortschritts für
eine Modernisierung unseres Landes für
eine Digitalisierung unseres Landes
gemeinsam zu nutzen und dafür die
entsprechenden Gelder Investitionen
gerade auch mit Forschung und
Entwicklung bereitzustellen damit dieses
Jahrzehnt gemeinsam genutzt werden kann
und das im Herzen Europas und auch in
der Verantwortung in der Welt weil es
auch darum geht wenn wir Europa zum
klimaneutralen Kontinent gestalten
wollen zugleich die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unseres Industriestandorts Deutschland
zu nutzen und die Modernisierung des
Staates auch im Ausdruck dessen wie wir
gemeinsam regieren nämlich im Sinne der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu gestalten als
eine Regierung die einlädt die lernfähig
ist und vor allen Dingen die im Dialog
mit dem Menschen in unserem Land Politik
für die zukünftigen Generationen
betreibt
bitte
ja guten Morgen auch von meiner Seite
sie sehen hier die Vorsitzenden und die
Spitzenkandidatinnen drei Jahre Parteien
die eigene Traditionen und die eigene
Sichtweisen haben und die haben wir in
den vergangenen Tagen in intensiven
Gesprächen eingebracht um auszuloten wie
es uns gelingen kann ein Bündnis zu
schmieden dann Bündnis dass unser Land
voranbringt und wir haben SPD auf
SPD-Seite Norbert Walter bojans und ich
gerade im Moment gemeinsam mit Olaf
Scholz unsere Parteigremien darüber
informiert dass wir sehr zuversichtlich
sind nach diesen sehr intensiven und
vertrauensvollen Gesprächen die auch
dazu geführt haben dass wir
Gemeinsamkeiten erarbeiten konnten dass
wir auch Einigungen erzielen konnten in
Konten entscheidenden Fragen dass wir
empfehlen können in
Koalitionsverhandlungen zu treten mit
dem mit den Bünden mit den
Bündnispartnern mit Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und mit den Freien Demokraten und
dieses Bündnis dass wir uns da
vorstellen das soll die Modernisierung
des Landes voranbringen die
Modernisierung unseres Staates auch in
der Regierung der Gesellschaft und die
vielen Veränderungen die vor uns liegen
die jetzt schon gerade angesprochen
worden sind sowohl die sozialökologische
Transformation unserer Industrie aber
auch unserer Gesellschaft der Wirtschaft
als auch andere Veränderungen wie
beispielsweise der digitale Wandel
verlangen den Menschen viel ab und
deswegen kommt es uns darauf an dass wir
den Menschen den Respekt auch bezeugen
und dass wir Ihnen auch die Sicherheit
geben dass sie in diesen Veränderungen
auch alle mitgenommen werden
meine Damen meine Herren die
letzten Tage waren geprägt von einem
besonderen Stil
das haben sich drei politische Kräfte
getroffen die in einem sehr diskreten
Rahmen sehr ernsthaft mit Neugier auf
die Positionen des Gegenübers Gespräche
organisiert haben
allein dieser Stil markiert schon eine
Zäsur in der politischen Kultur
Deutschlands
wir haben gemerkt dass die Art und Weise
wie wir uns mit den
zukunftsherausforderungen beschäftigen
viele Menschen in unserem Land
beeindruckt hat dass alleine durch die
Ernsthaftigkeit die wir gesprochen haben
viele Menschen Hoffnung geschöpft haben
das ein neuer Aufbruch für unser Land
möglich ist das hat bei uns und wie man
Eindruck ist bei allen Beteiligten den
Möglichkeitsraum erweitert und auch neue
Fantasie neue politische Fantasie
möglich gemacht
die FDP versteht sich als eine Partei
der politischen Mitte
diese
gesprächskonstellation auf der
Bundesebene ist für uns neu wir sehen
darin aber eine Chance wenn so
unterschiedliche Parteien sich auf
gemeinsame Herausforderungen und
Lösungsangebote verständigen könnten
dann liegt darin auch eine Chance unser
Land insgesamt
zusammenzuführen dann besteht die Chance
dass eine mögliche Koalition größer wird
als die Summe nur ihrer Teile
wir haben intensiv gesprochen und wir
haben uns nicht um Formel Kompromisse
bemüht
wir haben mit der
Eigenart gebrochen politische
Unterschiede
zuzudecken sondern wir haben uns um
klare Richtungsentscheidungen bemüht
dabei kommt es immer zu einem geben und
nehmen aber Fortschritt setzt voraus
dass es klare richtungsanzeigen gibt und
solche klaren richtungsanzeigen die
haben wir erreicht
aus meiner Sicht will ich hervorheben
dass es klare finanzielle Leitplanken
gibt die die Nachhaltigkeit der
öffentlichen Finanzen mit dem Respekt
vor den Grenzen der Belastungsfähigkeit
der Menschen verbinden auch entlastungs-
wir haben zum zweiten ein Programm
skizziert für die
Entbürokratisierung und
Entfesselung unseres Landes damit privat
und öffentliche Vorhaben wieder möglich
werden
wir wollen uns bemühen um
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit auch durch private
und öffentliche Investitionen in einem
erneuerten
sozialökologischen Ordnungsrahmen der
Marktwirtschaft
wir wollen einen Neustart für den
sozialen Aufstieg wollen sozialen
Aufstieg erleichtern von
Zuverdienstgrenzen bei einem neuen
Bürgergeld über Initiativen in der
Bildung bis hin zu Verbesserungen bei
der Altersversorgung der Menschen und
nicht zuletzt haben wir ein gemeinsames
Verständnis dafür gewonnen dass unsere
Gesellschaft insgesamt einen
liberalisierungsschub benötigt dass wir
eine Modernisierung unserer
Gesellschaftspolitik brauchen dass also
wie die Freiheit der Individuen stärken
wollen wir sind überzeugt nach diesen
Gesprächen
dass es lange Zeit
keine vergleichbare Chance gegeben hat
Gesellschaft
Wirtschaft und Staat zu modernisieren
lange Zeit hat es keine vergleichbare
modernisierungs-chance gegeben wie jetzt
und deshalb wollen wir diese Chance
nicht verstreichen lassen unser
sondierungsteam wird den Gremien der FDP
am Montag deshalb empfehlen in
Koalitionsgespräche einzutreten wir
glauben der große Gewinner einer solchen
Koalition wird am Ende nicht eine
einzelne Partei sein sondern unser Land
aus den Gesprächen der letzten Tage und
der letzten Stunden wir trafen uns nicht
unweit von hier oder Schienen nicht
unweit von hier im frühen Morgen ist
eine stabile Grundlage entstanden die
ist auch unser Partei
ermöglicht hoffentlich ermöglicht den
Koalitionsgespräche einzusteigen ein
Teil der Gespräche finden Sie für
schriftlich jetzt bei einem Papier das
zusammenfasst was wir erarbeitet haben
in den letzten Tagen und Wochen wir
haben jetzt unsererseits danach heute
morgen die Gremien sondierungsteam und
Parteirat schon befasst und werden jetzt
am Sonntag unserem Länder das ist der
kleine Parteitag ebenfalls empfehlen
aufgrund der gesammelten Erfahrung und
des Papiers das jetzt ausgeteilt wird in
Koalitionsgespräche einzusteigen ich
stimme den Vorrednerinnen ausdrücklich
zu dass in den letzten
Tagen aus einer
unklaren
ausgegangenen Bundestagswahl eine
Dynamik entstanden ist die diesen sich
abzeichnenden Regierungsbündnis eine
echte Schubkraft geben kann und es ist
die Dynamik und weniger die
Schnittmengen die ausgelotet worden die
die Hoffnung darauf setzt dass
tatsächlich
Großes geleistet werden kann
wenn man
nachts lange redet dann lernt man sich
ganz gut kennen
und das sagen wir mit großen Respekt es
ist tatsächlich so dass die Diskretion
und hohe Professionalität der
verschiedenen Partner als ermöglicht
haben so schnell zu diesem Ergebnis zu
kommen und eben diese Dynamik auszulösen
wenn drei Parteien miteinander reden und
die auch aus unterschiedlichen
politischen Wertevorstellungen stammen
ist völlig klar dass es Zumutungen gibt
und dass die Zumutungen getragen und
beschlossen werden müssen um dann nach
gemeinsames größeres möglich zu machen
dass das so gelungen ist ist nicht
selbstverständlich gewesen und zeigt
Christian Lindner hat es eben
angesprochen dass wir bereit sind zu
klaren Entscheidungen nicht zu einer
Politik des kleinsten gemeinsamen
Nenners sondern tatsächlich uns zu
entscheiden welches Projekt wie
angegangen wird beziehungsweise im
Suchen nach neuen Projekten noch eine
eigene Kreativität oder eben Fantasie
entsteht das kann weit tragen und so
hoffen Annalena baerbock und ich dass
unsere Partei den Weg
Koalitionsgesprächen frei macht wie weit
es tragen kann kann man an zwei Aspekten
in diesem sondierungspapier gut ablesen
es ist ja bekannt dass die
finanzpolitischen Vorstellungen
zumindest von FDP und Grünen weit
auseinander lagen und trotzdem ist es
gelungen den Parteien insofern Rechnung
zu tragen dass die Belastung die die FDP
nicht wollte nicht kommen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und trotzdem
genug Investitionsspielraum geschaffen
werden wird dass die
Zukunftsinvestitionen in Digitalisierung
in Klimaschutz in Forschung und
Entwicklung gestemmt werden können
insofern ein sehr zufriedenstellendes
Ergebnis nach langen Gesprächen und
Verhandlungen
es gibt einen zweiten würde ich sagen
Glut Kern dieses sich abzeichnen den
Bündnis und das ist die
gesellschaftliche Modernisierung wir
würden es so übersetzen dass die Politik
der Lebenswirklichkeit des Landes
endlich Rechnung trägt Menschen die in
Lebensform leben die bisher keinen
Rechtsstatus haben werden ihn bekommen
können wir werden die Vielfalt des
Landes auch juristisch und im
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht abbilden so
dass tatsächlich im Bereich der
gesellschaftlichen Politik eine
ein Aufschluss mit der Realität des
Lebens von vielen Menschen in diesem
Land gelingen kann das ist ein großes
Ziel und wir freuen uns und hoffen
darauf ist dann in den nächsten Jahren
verwirklichen zu können
ja meine Damen und Herren wir haben in
den letzten Tagen oft miteinander
gesprochen wir haben gestern und heute
Nacht sehr lange miteinander gesprochen
und die wichtigste Währung in diesem
Gesprächen war dass wir Respekt
voreinander hatten dass wir dadurch
Vertrauen zueinander gewonnen haben und
dass wir uns gesagt haben wir sitzen
hier nicht weil jeder für seine
Wählerinnen und Wähler allein
verantwortlich ist sondern weil wir
erstens gemeinsam verantwortlich sind
und weil wir auch verantwortlich sind
für die Menschen die uns nicht gewählt
haben
es ging nicht darum nur den kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenner ausfindig zu machen
sondern es ging darum dass uns bewusst
ist wir haben eine sehr große Aufgabe
als die drei Parteien im Deutschen
Bundestag die wirklich in der in der
Zeit in der Lage sind Verantwortung zu
übernehmen die eine gemeinsame
Vorstellung davon haben wie Fortschritt
in der Zukunft aussehen kann und die
dadurch aber auch ihre unterschiedlichen
Akzente zur Geltung bringen konnten es
ging um viele von vornherein
feststehende große Gemeinsamkeiten dass
uns klar ist wir müssen noch ein Zacken
zulegen im Klimaschutz wir müssen
technologisch wieder weiter an die
Spitze kommen die Digitalisierung ist
eine riesige Herausforderung aber eben
auch immer in sozialer Verantwortung in
dem Wissen dass Sicherheit im Wandel nur
möglich ist mit Sicherheit durchwandeln
und vor diesem Hintergrund glaube ich
haben wir uns gut zusammengefunden wir
haben Schwerpunkte in den Feldern die
ich eben genannt habe gesetzt wir haben
eben auch gegeben und genommen und wir
können mit gutem Gewissen für das Land
insgesamt unseren Gremien in der Partei
vorschlagen dass wir auf der Grundlage
dieser Sondierungen wir sind ja noch
nicht in Koalitionsverhandlungen jetzt
Koalitionsverhandlungen aufnehmen
sollten dass wir viele dieser Punkte die
wir angesprochen haben vertiefen sollten
und da geht es eben auf der einen Seite
darum was ist in diesem Land alles was
steht an was ist zu investieren wie wird
die Finanzierung sichergestellt und ich
glaube dass die Sondierung gezeigt hat
dass das in ein Gleichgewicht zu bringen
ist mit dem jeder der Partner leben kann
und vor allen Dingen mit dem wir
insgesamt das Land nach vorn bringen
dass macht uns zuversichtlich dass wir
nachdem wir heute schon einmal den
Parteivorstand der SPD informiert haben
heute Nachmittag noch mal auf der
Grundlage unser gemeinsam Papiers
zusammentreten und auch um das Votum
bitten
info-koalitionsverhandlungen einzutreten
und die dann hoffentlich auch zu einem
Erfolg zum guten Erfolg für dieses Land
zu bringen danke
vielen Dank bevor wir jetzt zu ihren
Fragen kommen ein kurzer Hinweis noch
sofern Sie Ihre Fragen nicht direkt an
jemanden adressieren wird immer nur ein
Vertreter ein Vertreterin propartei
Antworten die erste Frage kommt von
Herrn Rinke von Reuters bitteschön ich
habe eine Frage an Herrn Scholz nochmal
zu dem finanzierungsaspekt Absage an
eine veränderte Schuldenbremse und
Steuererhöhung wie wollen Sie
sicherstellen dass diese vielen Vorhaben
die ja auch mit drin stehen jetzt
finanziert werden können weil im
Wahlkampf das ja so klang als ob das
eigentlich mit dieser doppelten Absage
nicht funktionieren kann können Sie das
etwas erläutern bitte
wir haben
dem großen Gespräch mit den Bürgern und
Bürgern unterschiedliche Vorschläge
gehabt wie wir das Steuersystem besser
austarieren können aber die Vorschläge
die dort gemacht worden sind sind
größtenteils nicht darauf gegangen mehr
Einnahmen des Staates zu organisieren
mit dem was wir jetzt hier miteinander
vereinbart haben besteht der fiskalische
Spielraum den wir brauchen für das was
notwendig ist das betrifft die
Investitionen die wir brauchen auch die
anderen Fragestellungen die hier
aufgegriffen sind und selbstverständlich
glauben wir dass wir in diesem Rahmen
das alles realisieren können
die nächste Frage kommt von Herrn Ismer
vom Tagesspiegel ja ich hätte auch noch
mal ganz kurz eine Frage an Sie Herr
Scholz ein zentrales Thema das
Wahlkampfes war Respekt und
Gerechtigkeit und sie haben natürlich
auch sehr stark damit geworben dass die
Reichen in diesem Land ein kleinen oder
etwas höheren Beitrag leisten sollen man
sieht jetzt schon sehr viel Kritik auch
vom linken Parteiflügel das ist das
nicht gibt fürchten sie da Probleme und
bedauern Sie dass sie sich da nicht
durchsetzen können und an Herrn Lindner
vielleicht die gleiche Frage noch mal
von Herrn Rinke wie wollen sie die
gewaltigen Zukunft Investitionen
sicherstellen wenn man ab 2023 zu
Schuldenbremse zurückkehrt
Respekt ist die ganz große
Herausforderung für das Miteinander in
unserer Gesellschaft das halte ich für
ganz ganz zentral dass wir im 21
Jahrhundert es schaffen dass das
Miteinander wieder eine größere Rolle
spielt dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
einander auf Augenhöhe begegnen dass
niemand sich als etwas Besseres
empfindet und das ist genau das was mit
den
Zielsetzungen die wir verfolgt haben und
die hier sich wiederfinden auch
angesprochen ist zum Beispiel die Frage
des Mindestlohns zum Beispiel die Frage
ordentlicher Tarifverträge und
ordentlicher Bezahlung zum Beispiel dass
man sich darauf verlassen kann dass es
ein stabiles Rentenniveau gibt zum
Beispiel dass wir genügend und auch
bezahlbare Wohnung bauen so dass man gut
zurechtkommen kann zum Beispiel die
Frage einer besseren Perspektive für die
Kinder all die Themen über die wir
öffentlich gesprochen haben und die auch
jetzt eine Rolle spielen insofern ist
das eine Aufgabe die wir lösen werden
denn das geht ja um einzelne konkrete
Politiken die wir umsetzen wollen aber
es geht auch darum dass wir das
Miteinander neu organisieren als eine
Gesellschaft die zusammenhält und in der
jeder seinen Beitrag leisten kann und
jede egal ob man Rechtsanwalt ist oder
eben dafür sorgt dass das Essen auf den
Tisch kommt und das die Lebensmittel
verkauft werden können im Supermarkt
oder das die Bänder in den Fabriken
ordentlich bestückt werden können alles
das sind die haben die wir haben und das
werden wir gemeinsam so anpacken
als nächstes gab ja noch eine Frage an
mich im sondierungspapier ent dem
sondierungspapier entnehmen Sie viele
Vorhaben um soziale Teilhabe und
sozialen Aufstieg in Deutschland zu
erleichtern es ist ein gemeinsames Ziel
dass die Lebenschancen in unserem Land
nicht mehr so stark von der familiären
Herkunft vom Zufall der Geburt abhängen
und da finden sie vom Bildungsbereich
über einen veränderten
aufstiegsorientierten Sozialstaat viele
gemeinsam getragene Anliegen und im
sondierungspapier finden Sie ebenfalls
zahlreiche Maßnahmen mit denen alle
notwendigen privaten und öffentlichen
ich betone privaten und öffentlichen
Investitionsmittel aktiviert werden
können um Zukunftsaufgaben in
Deutschland zu finanzieren
als nächstes der Kollege von der Michael
Wüllenweber Welt Fernsehen eine Frage an
Herrn Frau beerburg hatte ja angedeutet
dass es noch Gespräche gegeben hat bis
tief in die Nacht was war das Thema dann
in der Nacht noch was als letztes
sozusagen vom Eis geschoben worden ist
und mussten sich die Parteivorsitzenden
da noch einmal einklinken hat es dann
noch mal Gespräche gegeben von denen wir
nichts wissen und vielleicht wenn ich
darf noch eine zweite Frage wir wissen
ja Olaf Scholz soll Kanzler werden aber
wissen ansonsten zu Personalien ja nicht
ist dieses Thema komplett um schimpft
worden oder hat sich da eventuell etwas
abgezeichnet das Christian Lindner
Finanzminister wird Robert Habeck auch
weiß und Frau Bär war vielleicht
Außenministerin irgendwas in der Art
wurde da schon diskutiert wenn sie es
auch nicht verraten wollen vielleicht
wurde das diskutiert
Weber zu ihrer ersten Frage die
Generalsekretäre und der
Bundesgeschäftsführer haben auf der
Basis unserer Gesprächsnotizen eine
Beratungsgrundlage erarbeitet und diese
Beratungsgrundlage haben wir gestern in
einer mehrstündigen intensiven
konstruktiven Sitzungen bis in die
frühen Morgenstunden als
Parteivorsitzende Kanzlerkandidat
bearbeitet dabei kamen alle notwendigen
Themen zur Sprache zu ihrer zweiten
Frage nein
bitte
ja trotz allem was Sie gesagt haben ist
das ganze Feld der Finanzierung in dem
sondierungspapier ja doch hinreichend
unkonkret
gibt es konkretere Absprachen die hier
nicht drin stehen oder müssen sie
tatsächlich über das konkrete noch sehr
ausführlich reden die zweite Frage wie
groß ist die Gefahr dass das Ganze doch
noch in den Koalitionsverhandlungen
scheitert
naja das ist ja das ist ja Sinn und
Zweck von Koalitionsverhandlungen dass
man auch noch was zu besprechen hat
sonst bräuchte es diese
koalitionsverhandlung nicht und
natürlich wird es bei den Finanzen aber
auch bei allen anderen Themenfeldern sie
sehen ja dass dieses Papier relativ
knapp gefasst ist überall auch noch
Konkretisierungen geben und deswegen
werden wir jetzt alle unseren Parteien
vorschlagen in diese
Koalitionsverhandlungen gemeinsam
einzutreten und dann in dem Geiste den
wir gerade beschrieben hatten der
letzten Tage diese
Koalitionsverhandlungen auch führen weil
es natürlich auch da darum gehen wird
dass man sich nicht auf Formel
Kompromisse und den kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenner einigt sondern das
was wir an Aufbruch für dieses
Jahrzehnte Erneuerung brauchen dann auch
gemeinsam wirklich in die Wege leiten
Frau Becker bitte von der ARD
eine Frage an Herrn Habig und einer eine
Herrn Lindner Herr Habeck soweit ich das
jetzt gesehen habe steht das Tempolimit
nicht drin und CO2-Preis habe ich auch
nicht gelesen sondern Emissionshandel
wie glücklich sind sie darüber und Herr
Lindner
aktienrente innerhalb der gesetzlichen
ist offensichtlich jetzt auch nicht
vorgesehen sondern als Extra posten aber
dafür der Mindestlohn 12 Euro wie
glücklich sind Sie mit diesen beiden
Dingen
wir haben das in unseren statements
wir haben es in unseren Statements
angesprochen dieses Papier zeichnet wir
haben es in der Mens angesprochen dieses
Papier zeichnet sich insgesamt dadurch
aus dass es sich bemüht eine Klarheit zu
schaffen und so ist es richtig das
Tempolimit konnten wir nicht durchsetzen
an anderen Stellen sind wir sehr
zufrieden wie der Text gearbeitet ist
und das
Interessante daran ist dass wir auch in
diesen langen Stunden nicht in einem
Geist der Sieg und Niederlage gedacht
untergearbeitet haben sondern das
Entstehens einer stabilen Grundlage von
Gemeinsamkeit und was die Frage von
Maßnahmen für den Klimaschutz angeht so
sind wir der Meinung dass das so ein
dierungspapier und die Gespräche die ist
die dazu geführt haben ausreichend
Maßnahmen nennt die dann in den
Koalitionsgesprächen aus buchstabiert
werden können um das Paris Ziel
einzuhalten und Deutschland tatsächlich
in wenigen anderthalb Jahrzehnten
klimaneutral machen zu können
dieses sondierungspapier enthält aus
unserer Sicht
äußerst ambitionierte Ideen damit
Deutschland bald eine dekarbonisierte
technologienation ist für uns ist das
eine enorme Chance
Wohlstand mit
ökologischer Sensibilität zu verbinden
ich glaube dass keine andere
Konstellation als diese in der Lage ist
diese Herausforderung zu stellen
Deutschland kann vorbildhaft in Europa
und der Welt damit werden und zu Ihrer
Frage was die Alterssicherung angeht
selbstverständlich können Sie natürlich
so kurz das Papier insgesamt noch nicht
überblickt haben aber ich will sie nur
einladen genau die Passage zu
Alterssicherung und zum Sozialstaat noch
einmal sich vorzulegen es gibt den
Einstieg in eine teilweise
Kapitaldeckung der gesetzlichen Rente
wir wissen dass das für unsere Gespräch
Partner ein großer Schritt ist und wir
sind dankbar für diese Bereitschaft
diesen Schritt mit uns gemeinsam zu
gehen darüber hinaus haben wir uns
darauf verständigt auch die private
Säule der Altersversorgung zu prüfen
unterschiedliche Instrumente die das
bisherige System der dritten Säule
weiterentwickeln können miteinander zu
besprechen und wir haben verabredet den
Sparer Pauschbetrag seit 2009 erst
einmal wieder zu erhöhen was für viele
die etwa ein alternativer Anlageformen
wie etf-produkte sparen ebenfalls
entlastet also insgesamt ist das was
hier gelungen ist für unser Land eine
sehr weitreichende Bewegung und ich will
noch mal sagen dass ich da sehr dankbar
bin dass wir auf sehr offene
Gesprächspartnerinnen und
Gesprächspartner getroffen sind
der Mindestlohn ist hier verabredet das
war ein Anliegen von SPD und Bündnis 90
die Grünen das muss man akzeptieren dass
es hier an Anliegen gibt und diesem
Anliegen haben wir im Sinne des Gebens
und Nehmens entsprochen wir sind
wiederum dankbar dass in diesem
Zusammenhang eine Verbesserung bei den
sogenannten Midijobs und der Einstieg in
die Dynamisierung der Höhe des Minijobs
möglich geworden ist das war ein Weg den
unsere Gesprächspartnerinnen und
Gesprächspartner gegangen sind der uns
wiederum ein Entgegenkommen bei
Mindestlohn sehr erleichtert hat auch
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar wenn ich das
alleine schon so darstelle bei Rente und
bei Mindestlohn sehen Sie von welchem
Geist diese Gespräche geprägt waren es
ging nicht darum dass irgendjemanden das
Leben erschwert werden soll es ging
nicht darum irgendjemanden
Schwierigkeiten zu bereiten sondern
Gutes für das Land zu erreichen und das
ist in war sehr beeindruckenden Balance
gelungen ich will vielleicht noch eines
hinzufügen wer sich die Programme
nebeneinander legt und dieses Papier
dazu legt er wird sehen das ist
Abweichungen gibt das ist aber der Sinn
dieser Sondierungsgespräche und wenn sie
sich anguckt wird sehen da ist nicht hat
sich nicht der eine zu Lasten des
anderen durchgesetzt sondern ist mit
seinen jeweiligen Schwerpunkten
Christian Lindner hat das angesprochen
bei uns das Thema Rente das Thema
Mindestlohn aber eben auch das Thema
bezahlbarer Wohnraum das hat sich ja
zusammengefügt mit den Überlegungen der
jeweils anderen Partner und ihren
Schwerpunkten nicht zu einem
Sammelsurium sondern eben zu einem
gemeinsamen Ganzen und ich glaube das
macht den den Charme dieses Papiers aus
es gibt den Rahmen der jetzt gefüllt
werden kann mit vielen konkreten Punkten
mit denen die jeweiligen Parteien leben
können aber ich sage es noch mal nicht
weil sie jeweils ihre Wählerinnen und
Wähler bedienen müssen sondern weil wir
was für dieses Land tun müssen und das
ist unser gemeinsam Verständnis ich
finde dafür ist das ein sehr guter
Rahmen mit sehr guten Zielen die darin
beschrieben sind weil es geht am Ende
darum dass wir den Wohlstand sichern und
dabei alle mitnehmen
der Kollege im grauen Pullover
ja Holger Mühle wohne Generalanzeiger
Lindner weil ich vermute dass die FDP
den längsten Weg hier zur zurücklegen
müssen ich würde gerne wissen ob sie
sich in der Konstellation wie sie sich
jetzt derzeit darstellt wohlfühlen
ob sie das Spiel dort haben wo sie es
haben wollten und von SPD und Grünen
wüsste ich gerne wie schmerzhaft es für
sie jeweils ist dass die Vermögensteuer
nicht kommt
wir sind eine eigenständige Partei und
wir bemessen unseren Eintritt in
Koalitionen danach wo wir viel liberale
Politik umsetzen können und wir sind
sehr zufrieden mit den Möglichkeiten die
wir hier gemeinsam gefunden haben uns
gefällt das sondierungspapier Aufbruch
und Fortschritt für Deutschland sind
möglich und die Dinge die uns wichtig
sind auch
Punkt
kann ich nur wiederholen alle haben
gegeben alle haben auch in den Bereichen
wo es wirklich ein Aufbruch und
Fortschritt braucht und das Leitmotiv
eine Gesellschaft auf der Höhe unserer
Zeit auch in der zukünftigen Politik und
der zukünftigen Regierung
wiederzuspielen das ist der Geist den
dieses Papier gemeinsam Arbeit atmet und
zwar für alle Generationen in unserem
Land und über die Finanzierung haben wir
jetzt ja mehrfach gesagt dass wir die
Investitionen dafür gemeinsam durch
unterschiedliche Instrumente
bereitstellen
der Kollege im blauen Pullover bitte
Pioneer herr Scholz wie ist jetzt das
weitere Setting für die Verhandlungen
ist ein verhandlungsabschluss vor
Weihnachten weiterhin eine Kanzlerwahl
vor Weihnachten weiterhin realistisch
das weitere Setting wird besprochen wenn
die Parteien alle miteinander ihre
Entscheidung alle nacheinander
Entscheidungen getroffen haben das wird
wenn alles so läuft wie wir uns das
glaube ich miteinander gedacht haben
irgendwann am Montag der Fall sein und
dann werden auch die Generalsekretäre
und Bundesgeschäftsführer die
entsprechenden Vorbereitung für die
nächsten für die Koalitionsgespräche und
ähnliches treffen können vorher gar
nicht sinnvollerweise und dass wir
schnell fertig werden wollen und das vor
Weihnachten das hat glaube ich jede und
jeder von uns irgendwo schon mal gesagt
bitte
gerne mal nachfragen bei den Finanzen
also da habe ich bisher wenig Konkretes
gehört finde hier auch kaum Zahlen in
dem Papier aber vielleicht habe ich auch
übersehen deswegen noch mal die Frage
gibt es ganz konkrete Zahlen wie hoch
ist der Investitionsbedarf beim Thema
Klimaschutz zum Beispiel und da sie ja
die Schuldenbremse weiter einhalten
wollen wie groß sind die Summen die sie
auf anderen Wege dann irgendwie zusammen
bekommen
konkrete Finanzbedarf war jetzt nicht
Bestandteil unserer Sondierungsgespräche
sondern die gemeinsame Verabredung wie
es uns gelingen kann dass wir sowohl
private als auch öffentliche
Investitionen auch tatsächlich auf den
Weg bringen dazu ist es dringend
notwendig dass wir Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen dass
wir die Umsetzung von Vorhaben
beschleunigen und dazu haben wir uns die
Modernisierung des Staates und der
Verwaltung vorgenommen das ist glaube
ich der wichtigere Hebel natürlich sind
Investitionen notwendig in die Zukunft
dieses Landes in die Transformation die
wir uns vorgenommen haben aber wir sind
zuversichtlich dass wir dafür die Mittel
auch aufbringen werden
wir kommen zur letzten Frage hier
bitteschön
ist für den Deutschlandfunk eine Frage
an Herrn Scholz und an die übrigen auch
spd-parteivorsitzender die beiden sie
haben bezahlbares Wohnen erwähnt sie
haben damit Wahlkampf gemacht haben und
daran mieten Moratorium gefordert davon
steht jetzt nichts mehr drin sondern
dass man bestehende mietschutzregelungen
evaluieren verlängern möchte können Sie
sagen ist es mieten Moratorium oder
einer Begrenzung der mieten dann
komplett vom Tisch oder hoffen sie dass
sie den Koalitionsverhandlungen dann auf
was rausholen können danke wir haben
zunächst mal dafür Sorge getragen dass
die drängende Frage des fehlenden
Wohnraums aufgegriffen wird wir haben
einen Bündnis für das Wohnen vorgesehen
dass wir alle gemeinsam richtig finden
das aber uns ein ganz besonderes
Anliegen war denn es kommt bei der
Lösung dieses Problems zunächst mal
darauf an dass man etwas macht da müssen
nämlich alle zusammenarbeiten die
Gemeinden in Deutschland den kleinen
Städte die großen Städte die Landkreise
die 16 Länder der Bund da müssen die
Bauindustrie die Wohnungswirtschaft die
Mieterinnen und Mieter miteinander
kooperieren und wir müssen uns jeden Tag
darum
dass wir die notwendige Mobilisierung
Zustande kriegen damit es 400.000
Wohnungen pro Jahr gibt viele viele
Jahre lang und darunter auch 100.000
Sozialwohnungen sind das ist die
wichtigste Maßnahme wir haben sehr viele
mietschutzrechtliche Regelungen die sich
hier dort wiederfinden wo wir gesagt
haben wir werden sie evaluieren das ist
das eine was wichtiges und genau auf
Ihre Frage zielt und das zweite ist dass
wir natürlich auch die mit
schutzrechtlichen Regelungen die
befristet sind verlängern wollen das
sind zwei Dinge die genau hier
stattfinden und die auch das
Gesamtsetting für unseren
Handlungsrahmen abgeben den wir dort
haben denn wir müssen und wir werden das
Problem aufgreifen den Wohnraummangel
und die steigenden Preise
den Wohnraummangel zu bekämpfen und die
steigenden Preise auch zu bekämpfen
indem wir dafür sorgen dass es genügend
Wohnung gibt und ein ausreichenden
Mieterschutz
so dann bedanken wir uns herzliche ihr
Kommen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und
wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen Tag
tschüss tschüss
wir haben soeben die Vorsitzenden von
SPD Grünen und FDP gehört und auch die
den Spitzenkandidaten und die
Spitzenkandidatin in dem Falle haben wir
also gehört es gibt jetzt einen
sondierungspapier und darüber wollen wir
sprechen und einordnen mit unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondente Nicole Diekmann
in Berlin und natürlich stellt jederzeit
gerne eure Fragen Kommentare in der
jetzt eingeblendeten Mailadresse viele
von euch kennen die schon oder natürlich
auch direkt im Stream so es gibt jetzt
also ein sondierungspapier das bedeutet
dass die Vorsitzenden und die
Spitzenkandidaten in dem Falle
miteinander in Koalitionsgespräche
theoretisch treten wollen wenn dann aber
auch also die Parteien da jetzt jeweils
zustimmen so das ist alles ein bisschen
kompliziert wir wollen es jetzt hier
aber mal ganz konkret machen in diesem
Papier haben wir ja einiges gehört
Nicole wir haben zum Beispiel gehört der
Mindestlohn ja der soll kommen das war
eine Forderung der SPD das Tempolimit
zum Beispiel das war eine Forderung der
Grünen das soll es nicht geben kann man
irgendwie sagen wer sich da jetzt so ein
bisschen durchgesetzt hat wer hat da
jetzt am Ende irgendwie die meisten
Dinge reinbekommen also auf jeden Fall
durchgesetzt hat sich eine große
Euphorie das war gerade zu spüren da
übertraf man sich gegenseitig drin also
der Wille ist ganz stark miteinander
jetzt tatsächlich in die
Koalitionsgespräche zu gehen man will da
ja eventuell nächste Woche schon mit
anfangen und vor Weihnachten auch dann
mit fertig sein natürlich mit dem Ziel
dann eine Regierung zu bilden
wer sich durchgesetzt hat finde ich
jetzt noch ein bisschen früh die Frage
zu beantworten denn es gibt ja einen
Bereich und das sind die Finanzen der
hat im Vorfeld schon immer als der große
knackpunktbereich gegolten es ist jetzt
schon klar man geht nicht an die
Schuldenbremse man wird die nicht
aufweichen das ist gerade schon gesagt
worden und es wird aber auch keine
Vermögenssteuer geben da war ja die FDP
ganz drauf dass die auf keinen Fall
kommt das ist keine Steuerbelastungen
geben wird und Bürgerinnen und Bürger
gleichzeitig haben aber alle Beteiligten
eben noch mal gesagt es wird trotzdem
Investitionsspielraum geben es wird
trotzdem genug Geld geben um den Staat
zu modernisieren das ist ja ein großes
Schlagwort in dieser möglichen Koalition
Modernisierung auf Nachfragen wo
konkreten dieses Geld nun herkommen soll
für diese Investitionen da ist man so
ein bisschen ausgewichen das heißt
da könnte sich noch abzeichnen wer sich
dann im Endeffekt durchsetzt mit welchen
Instrumenten man da dann Geld generieren
will
ja wir haben es gehört Modernisierung
Reform Fortschritt das waren also immer
wieder Schlagworte die gefallen sind und
auf Scholz der als erstes gesprochen hat
nannte das ganz am Anfang die
industrielle Modernisierung die jetzt
kommen soll es geht darum Klimawandel
aufzuhalten und auch um den Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien das war ja so ein
ganz großes natürlich das größte
Themenfeld der Grünen was Ihnen
besonders wichtig war damit hat dann
auch Anna-Lena baerbock ihre kleine
kurze ihr kleines kurzes Statement
begonnen aber ist dazu denn auch schon
ein bisschen mehr zu diesem Thema was
alle Parteien auch sehr in den
Vordergrund gestellt haben ist dazu noch
ein bisschen mehr bekannt geworden ja
das war ja tatsächlich mal heute einen
Tag nach diesen sehr verschwiegenen sehr
diskreten Sondierungsgesprächen an dem
wirklich auch mal thematisch gesprochen
wurde inhaltlich und auch ein paar
pflücke eingeschlagen wurden also zwei
Prozent der Landfläche für Windkraft
sollen
verwendet werden
Solarkraft soll auf alle geeigneten
Dächer installiert werden der
Kohleausstieg soll bis 30 also schon
eher kommen und auch der Ausstieg aus
dem fossilen Verbrennermotor soll
möglichst Frühjahr als bisher geplant
stattfinden also zusammengefasst
klimapolitische
Aussagen sind gerade gemacht worden man
will schneller sein auch in diesem Punkt
und man will die erneuerbaren Energien
massiv ausbauen ihr habt auch schon
einiges kommentiert und auch Fragen
gestellt aber ich wollte jetzt erstmal
kurz hier auf eure Kommentare schauen
und zwar gab es hier schon ganz am
Anfang bei Youtube den Kommentar von
justifiedme ich glaube man kann schon
aus den ersten paar Sätzen verstehen
dass sich alle gut geeinigt haben und
das zu Papier gebracht haben ich glaube
die Ampel wird kommen dann haben wir
hier noch von Heidrun Burkhardt bei
Facebook ich hoffe auf die Ampel und bei
Youtube beispielsweise auch noch mal
hier Mister mafiale ich finde es gut
dass Grüne und FDP zusammenfinden können
das waren ja auch die die zuerst
miteinander gesprochen haben Nicole in
wie wichtig war das auch weil es viel
jetzt auch immer wieder bei von allen
die dort gesprochen haben immer wieder
die Worte es ist vertrauensvoll es ist
konstruktiv also damit auch so ein
bisschen die Rechtfertigung warum warum
man da vielleicht auch vorher so
verschwiegen war Christian Lindner
nannte ist glaube ich sogar ich habe
hier ein bisschen mitgeschrieben aber
ein kleines Zettel Chaos hier er nannte
es ein ganz besonderen Stil dieses Stil
markiert eine Zäsur in der politischen
Kultur vielleicht da so ein bisschen
auch die Frage an dich was ist denn
jetzt nämlich anders da auch zu vor vier
Jahren wo das ja auch wirklich eine
Hängepartie war bis es da dann am Ende
eine Regierung gab diese schweigen dass
manche meiner Berufskollegen in den
letzten Wochen auch schon fast beleidigt
kommentiert haben es ist ja nichts
durchgestochen worden es gab eben schon
von der Chefin der saarländischen SPD
Anke Rehlinger vor der Pressekonferenz
ein Tweet
da war zu lesen sehr gut und daneben das
Symbol für Ampel und das war schon das
indiskreteste was überhaupt passiert ist
dass vor der Pressekonferenz schon
festzustehen schien es hat sich dann der
bewahrheitet dass man sich tatsächlich
darauf geeinigt hat dieses Papiers
vorzulegen und jeweils den eigenen der
eigenen Partei Koalitionsgespräche zu
empfehlen das ist der sogenannte neue
Geist bzw ein Bestandteil dieses neuen
Geistes dass man also diskret war dass
man nicht durchgestochen hat der Presse
und dass man sehr freundlich sehr
ernsthaft und mit Neugier das war auch
das habe ich mir aufgeschrieben ein Wort
das Christian Lindner verwendet hat
miteinander umgegangen ist was ich finde
immer wieder mitgeschwungen ist in
dieser Pressekonferenz die zweigeteilt
war sich einmal um Inhalte gedreht hat
aber auch in der anderen Hälfte viel um
den Stil das war eine Polarisierung die
es in unserer Gesellschaft gibt und
gegen die man jetzt anarbeiten will
respekte gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt
das viel heute auch ein paar Mal Olaf
Scholz hat das auch im Wahlkampf immer
wieder verwendet und da will man gerade
grüne und die FDP die ja thematisch weit
auseinander liegen da will man jetzt ein
Zeichen setzen da will man eben wenn man
Christian Lindner eben zugehört hat
einen neuen Stil etablieren um auch
diese Polarisierung die in unserer
Gesellschaft voranschreitet auch Einheit
zu gebieten dann Vorbild zu sein um
diese Entwicklung
einzudämmen vielleicht auch zu stoppen
ihr habt viele Fragen gestellt auf einen
Plattformen und die möchten wir jetzt
natürlich auch gerne hier beantworten
und zwar heller Bomber bei Facebook
fragt Modernisierung des Staates das
haben wir ja gehört auch von Olaf Scholz
und auch den anderen wie sieht das aus
fragt Hella Bomber da sind die beiden
großen Stichworte einmal Digitalisierung
ist ja spätestens seit Corona allen klar
geworden da ist noch viel Luft nach oben
da hat Deutschland einiges nachzuholen
und was heute auch noch mal angesprochen
worden ist ist die Beschleunigung von
Genehmigungsverfahren das heißt also
eine endbürokratisierung das sind so die
großen Blöcke die jetzt heute unter
diesem unter dieser Überschrift
Modernisierung des Staates angesprochen
wurden
Harbeck hat auch ich habe mir das auch
aufgeschrieben
im Moment wo habe ich hat auch noch mal
einen Block da angesprochen hier geht es
so wie mir ja das ist das Problem wenn
man Staatsbürgerschaft
Recht das war das was Robert Habeck eben
angesprochen hat und da geht es unter
anderem anscheinend um die Zuwanderung
von Fachkräften da soll es ein
Punktesystem geben und
genau also man will anscheinend auch an
diesem Block um dem mal grob zu
umschreiben Migration ran genau
gesellschaftliche Modernisierung so
hatte er dieses große große Thema
genannt das passt natürlich auch viel
rein und das ist auch so natürlich ein
bisschen neben aus den Journalisten
Fragen die dann gestellt wurden hieß es
dann auch naja das Papier ist recht kurz
gibt es da nicht noch mehr konkrete
Punkte auf die man sich da jetzt
geeinigt hat aber da gab es dann also
auch die Ansage der Parteien dass das
natürlich jetzt erst wenn es zu
Koalitionsgesprächen kommt verhandelt
würde es gibt noch mehr Fragen von euch
und zwar haben wir hier die Frage von
der User Jan bei Facebook Habeck
baerbock oder Lindner wer wird Vize
unter Scholz und ich möchte gerne auch
noch eine Frage anhängen Nicole wurde
grundsätzlich Personalfragen irgendwie
auch schon ein bisschen gesprochen heute
ja das war auch eine Frage eine
Journalisten vor Ort sie hat eher
Christian Lindner gestellt und hat das
konkretisiert also würde Christian
Lindner deren jetzt Finanzminister und
würde Robert Habeck auch was bekommen
und Anna Lena baerbock auch er wollte
gar nicht so genau wissen ob jetzt diese
konkreten Posten schon verteilt sind
sondern ob man überhaupt darüber
gesprochen hat sagt Christian Lindner
kurz und knapp beantwortet mit nein das
ist
ob das so stimmt wir gehen jetzt mal
davon aus dass Christian Lindner nicht
lügt das ist natürlich auch noch mal ein
wichtiger Punkt für
Koalitionsverhandlungen und da wird man
sich jetzt sicherlich nicht versuchen in
der Öffentlichkeit gegenseitig ins
Gehege zu kommen weil das ja wie gesagt
ein heikler Punkt ist
was euch hier am meisten in den
Kommentaren interessiert und ich glaube
die Frage ist aber von unserer Seite
sehr schnell beantwortet war haben sie
sich denn zum Thema Cannabis geeignet
geeinigt nein das Cannabis Thema legales
kiffen hat es glaube ich die Bild heute
überschrieben
wurde gar nicht angesprochen in der
Pressekonferenz
sepm möchte bei Youtube wissen und da
wird es dann jetzt auch noch mal genau
geht's natürlich euch interessieren auch
die inhaltlichen Themen uns alle sepm
bei Youtube möchte wissen was haben die
Grünen denn jetzt durchgesetzt keine
Vermögenssteuer kein Tempolimit
Schuldenbremse weiterhin also was haben
die Grünen denn genau für sich
vielleicht durchsetzen können ist das
schon was konkreter geworden naja das
würde ich vor allem unter dem Schlagwort
massiver Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien das ist ja ein Herzensanliegen
dass er das Kernanliegen der Grünen
früherer cola-ausstieg genauso wie ein
früherer Abschied vom fossilen
Verbrennungsmotor
da würde ich sagen sind schon einige
Kernpunkte der Grünen mit drin
und Martin l das ist auch eine Frage die
dreht sich jetzt hier um den Klimaschutz
Martin Elber Youtube möchte wissen was
ist denn jetzt mit dem Pariser
Klimaschutz Abkommen wird man alles
dafür tun dass es auch eingehalten wird
naja also das ist natürlich die
mindestvorgabe ne ein Abkommen dass man
mit unterzeichnet hat auch zu erfüllen
und wir haben auch eine kleine kurze
Grafik mal vorbereitet weil was im
Vorfeld jetzt auch interessant war war
das natürlich auch wir beim ZDF
Politbarometer gefragt haben was möchten
denn die Menschen was wünschen die sich
und da war dann doch auch interessant
dass also der Großteil sich die Ampel
wünscht und da wollen wir mal ganz kurz
reinschauen wie viele Prozent das genau
sind unter den Befragten
62% der deutschen finden eine
Ampelkoalition gut nur 19% schlecht die
anderen möglichen koalitionen sind
deutlich unbeliebter
und dann natürlich auch die Frage wer
soll denn dann am Ende auch der Kanzler
sein wobei da ist es auch relativ
eindeutig aber wir schauen trotzdem mal
kurz rein was die Umfrage da ergeben hat
und vielleicht ist sie auch noch gar
nicht da ich kann es verraten Olaf
Scholz von der SPD Überraschung das
wünschen sich 75 laut ZDF Politbarometer
fänden ist 75% der Deutschen eher gut
wenn der Sozialdemokrat tatsächlich
Bundeskanzler werden würde nur 17
Prozent eher schlecht
und da kommt natürlich schließt sich die
Frage an wenn das jetzt so deutlich ist
dass sich da auch in der innerhalb der
deutschen die allermeisten wohl also die
Ampel wünschen heißt dass dann aber auch
gleichzeitig wenn man jetzt die
Politikerinnen und Politiker fragt
insbesondere die FDP heißt das denn
Jamaika das ist jetzt ganz vom Tisch
dass man da überhaupt noch mal dran
denkt weil wir erinnern uns das war ja
eigentlich mal das was die FDP sich eher
gewünscht hatte oder das stimmt das war
ganz klar im Wahlkampf auch die Aussage
der FDP genauso wie er auf an Christian
Lindner die Aussage war ihm viele
jegliche Fantasie sich eine Ampel
vorzustellen das klang jetzt heute sehr
anders
die Jamaika never say never es ist
theoretisch ja immer noch möglich ist
aber mit dem heutigen Tag ja noch mal
ein Stückchen unwahrscheinlicher
geworden man hätte sich da ja heute auch
hinstellen und sagen können wir haben
jetzt sondiert es tut uns leid die
Schnittmengen sind nicht groß genug wir
sehen hier überhaupt keine Chance dafür
eine stabile
entscheidungskräftige Regierung zu
bilden die unser Land voranbringt wir
haben jetzt das Gegenteil eben in der
Pressekonferenz gehört das heißt damit
hat man sich weiter ein Stück von
Jamaika verabschiedet und was man ja
auch sagen muss seit der Wahl hat es in
der CDU ja auch gewaltige Bewegungen
gegeben Armin Laschet der jetzt einen
Rückzug vom Parteivorsitz angekündigt
hatten Prozess der jetzt irgendwie in
Gang kommt man weiß noch nicht so ganz
genau wie damit ist Jamaika auch noch
mal ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher
geworden denn eine wahnsinnig
unsortierte Union ist natürlich auch
kein sehr zuverlässiger
Verhandlungspartner für die FDP
Joe Valero stellt dabei Youtube jetzt
eigentlich genau die richtige Frage was
es sich wahrscheinlich einige irgendwie
fragen was glauben die Damen nennt er
uns was glauben die Damen denn jetzt
wird in der CDU-Zentrale an Reaktionen
herauskommen
Armin Laschet hat es an dem Abend an dem
er ja auch seinen Rückzug angekündigt
hat betont es ist bis zur letzten
Sekunde Gesprächsbereitschaft da das ist
das Signal das von ihm ausgeht für
Jamaika das heißt es gibt eigentlich
keinen Grund jetzt diese Tür
zuzuschlagen das hätte er ja an diesem
Abend auch schon machen können die
Vorzeichen haben sich dadurch nicht
geändert bis zur letzten Sekunde das ist
ja eine sehr sehr klare Aussage
und bevor wir noch mehr von euren Fragen
aufnehmen wollen wir doch aber auch noch
mal kurz in die wichtigsten Statements
reinhören die wir eben gerade in dieser
Pressekonferenz von den Parteispitzen
und den Spitzenkandidaten gehört haben
wir haben uns auf einen Papier einen
Text zur Sondierung verständigt der
jetzt die Grundlage für die Entscheidung
in den Parteien bilden kann und aus der
Perspektive die ich für mich formulieren
will ist das auch ein sehr gutes
Ergebnis es macht deutlich dass in
Deutschland eine Regierung gebildet
werden kann die dafür Sorge tragen
möchten dass wir einen Fortschritt
erreichen ein Fortschritt der möglich
und notwendig ist in vielen vielen
Feldern unser gesellschaftlichen
Entwicklung unser wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung und auch im Hinblick auf die
Aufgaben die wir als Land in Europa
haben insgesamt kann man sehr spüren
hier ist ein Aufbruch möglich getragen
von den dreien Parteien die hier
zusammenkommen für mich persönlich dass
wir Dich gerne noch sagen es ist sehr
bemerkenswert wie vertrauensvoll und
konstruktiv die Gespräche über auch
unterschiedliche Ausgangspositionen
stattfinden das ist etwas das ich als
sehr sehr wohltuend empfinde weil es
schon jetzt während der Sondierung dann
hoffentlich bei Koalitionsverhandlungen
und noch viel mehr wenn es darum geht
miteinander zu regieren dazu beitragen
kann dass hier das angepackt wird was
für Deutschland notwendig ist das haben
wir uns vorgenommen und wenn die
Zusammenarbeit weiter so gut klappt dann
glaube ich wird das auch eine gute
Zukunft werden für unser Land das ist
vor einmal ger
echten Mann und eine Erneuerung der
sozialen Marktwirtschaft hin zu einer
sozialökologischen Marktwirtschaft in
Deutschland und damit auch in Europa zu
verankern und zugleich dieses Jahrzehnt
des Fortschritts für eine Modernisierung
unseres Landes für eine Digitalisierung
unseres Landes gemeinsam zu nutzen und
dafür die entsprechenden Gelder
Investitionen gerade auch mit Forschung
und Entwicklung bereitzustellen damit
dieses Jahrzehnt gemeinsam genutzt
werden kann
diese gesprächskonstellation auf der
Bundesebene ist für uns neu wir sehen
darin aber eine Chance wenn so
unterschiedliche Parteien sich auf
gemeinsame Herausforderungen und
Lösungsangebote verständigen könnten
dann liegt darin auch eine Chance unser
Land insgesamt zusammenzuführen dann
besteht die Chance dass eine mögliche
Koalition größer wird als die Summe nur
ihrer Teile
wir sind überzeugt nach diesen
Gesprächen
dass es lange Zeit
keine vergleichbare Chance gegeben hat
Gesellschaft
Wirtschaft und Staat zu modernisieren
wir haben es gehört da sieht man also
oder man hörte drei sehr
unterschiedliche Parteien eigentlich
sprechen hier von einer Chance dass sie
da jetzt möglicherweise eben zusammen
gehen nichtsdestotrotz es sind eben drei
sehr unterschiedliche Parteien Nicole
was kann denn da jetzt aber auch
vielleicht noch schief gehen auf dem
dann doch noch längeren Weg bis hin zu
einer möglichen Koalition
das ist die große Frage dafür
sind jetzt die nächsten Wochen
wahrscheinlich sehr aufschlussreich das
ist tatsächlich sehr schwer zu sagen
nach einer Woche in der so wenig nach
außen gedrungen ist aber ich habe es ja
vorhin schon mal gesagt der große
Knackpunkt sind die Finanzen man hat es
ja gerade auch in den O-Tönen gehört man
ist sich in allen drei Parteien darüber
einig es muss investiert werden es muss
modernisiert werden wir haben Christian
Lindner gerade gehört mit einem
Superlativ die Zeit gab es gab noch nie
eine Zeit mit so großen Chancen für
Modernisierung wie diese jetzt ja aber
die gibt es eben nicht für umsonst das
Geld muss irgendwo herkommen an Tasten
der Schuldenbremse ist vom Tisch
steuererhöhungen sind vom Tisch das
könnte ich mir vorstellen ist die große
Frage an der ist noch brechen könnte in
diesen Koalitionsverhandlungen woher das
Geld nehmen wen belasten wenig belasten
und wie sieht da jetzt so der zeitliche
Fahrplan aus weil die Grünen haben
gesagt sie wollen jetzt oder müssen auch
erst noch mal auf einem kleinen
Parteitag länderrad miteinander sprechen
bei der FDP sind die Partei Gremien die
irgendwie zustimmen müssen also wie ist
der der zeitliche Plan jetzt zunächst
mal ja also passend zur Ampel will man
jetzt tatsächlich Gas geben die SPD
sprintet da voran da soll heute noch der
Parteivorstand informiert werden
die Grünen sind dann die nächsten in
dieser Chronologie am Sonntag soll es
den sogenannten Länderrat geben das ist
ein kleiner Parteitag und am Montag will
dann die FDP intern klären ob sie grünes
Licht Gericht aus ihrer Partei aus der
Fraktion für Koalitionsgespräche das
geht jetzt ziemlich schnell
vielen Dank Nicole Diekmann für deine
Analyse für jetzt auch noch mal diesen
Ausblick ZDF Hauptstadt in Berlin
Dankeschön sehr gerne
und auch euch natürlich vielen Dank für
eure Fragen und dass ihr da jetzt auch
so lange zugeschaut habt seid ihr jetzt
doch eine Weile gedauert es bleibt auf
jeden Fall spannend nächste Woche mit
Sicherheit sehen wir uns wieder dann
hier bei ZDF heute live bis dahin
tschüss